THE TOP OF THE BROADCAST, THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT SPEAK FOR
TODAY'S GOP.
JOINING US NOW A CONSERVATIVE
LAWYER, GEORGE CONWAY.
CLEARLY THIS WAS VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE'S STRONGEST REBUKE OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
I WISH WE PLAYED THE APPLAUSE AT
THE FEDERALIST SOCIETY, BECAUSE
IT WASN'T LIKE THERE WAS A
ROUSING STANDING OVATION AND HE
WAS CARRIED OUT ON THE SHOULDERS
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE FEDERALIST
SOCIETY AFTER THAT.
>> I'M NOT ABLE TO JUDGE THE
AMOUNT OF APPLAUSE ON THE VIDEO.
THE CONSERVATIVE LAWYERS FOR THE
MOST PART AGREE WITH PENCE AND
WERE APPALLED WHAT HAPPENED
JANUARY 6th AND HAVE NO QUALMS
ABOUT SAYING THAT.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED WITH, YOU
KNOW, BILL BARR.
BILL BARR WENT IN.
YOU KNOW, TO HIS CREDIT YOU CAN
CRITICIZE HIM FOR OTHER THINGS,
BUT HE TOLD THE PRESIDENT THAT
NO, YOU CAN'T SEIZE THE BALLOT
BOXES OR VOTING MACHINES AND HE
TOLD THE PRESIDENT TO HIS FACE
IN THE OVAL OFFICE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP THAT YOU LOST THE ELECTION
AND THERE IS NO BASE TO CLAIM
FRAUD AND HE GOT SCREAMED AT IT
FOR IT AND ALL OF THE LAWYERSA
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT
THREATENED TO RESIGN.
THAT IS WHY TRUMP HAD A LOUSY
SET OF LAWYERS IN THE END.
THE REAL LAWYERS AND LAW FIRMS
WOULDN'T HELP HIM.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT MAKES
ABSOLUTE SENSE FOR PENCE TO HAVE
PICKED THIS AUDIENCE TO MAKE
THIS STATEMENT AT THIS TIME.
>> WELL, THE CONTEXT OF THIS IS
ALSO IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE SEEN PENCE AIDES
TESTIFYING ONE BY ONE
COOPERATING TO THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
WE FOUND OUT THEY ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE RECORDS FROM THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WILL REACT TO PENCE'S
COMMENTS.
WHAT DOES IT DO TO PENCE'S
STANDING FOR HIS OWN
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS?
>> WELL, I THINK WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT.
WE ALREADY SAW THAT.
I THINK WHAT REALLY TRIGGERED
THE SPEECH THIS WEEK WAS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT
THAT HE ISSUED OVER THE WEEKEND
WHERE HE BASICALLY SAID THAT THE
PERSON THAT SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED IS MIKE PENCE FOR
NOT OVERTURNING THE ELECTION.
HE IS URGING AN INVESTIGATION OF
MIKE PENCE, WHICH IS COMPLETELY
INSANE.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THERE IS NO
UPSIDE FOR MIKE PENCE IN DONALD
TRUMP ANYMORE IF TRUMP IS GOING
TO BE SAYING THAT.
IT IS JUST BETTER FOR MIKE PENCE
IN THE EYES OF HISTORY TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF THAT IN A MORE
EMPHATIC WAY, WHICH IS WHAT HE
DID TODAY TO HIS GREAT CREDIT.
>> DOES IT MAKE ANY SENSE THAT
THE RNC PUT OUT THE OFFICIAL
RESOLUTION EQUATING A VIOLENT
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL WITH, YOU
KNOW, I WANT TO GET THE WORDING
EXACTLY RIGHT, WITH
LEGITIMATE -- I FORGOT THE
WORDING.
LEGITIMATE POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
>> RIGHT.
IF THEY WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR
BETWEEN POLITICAL DISCOURSE AND
THE VIOLENCE AT THE CAPITOL THEY
COULD HAVE BEEN MORE SPECIFIC
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
THEY ARE LUMPING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER, INCLUDING THE
INSURRECTIONISTS.
TRUMP IS TALKING ABOUT PARDONING
THESE PEOPLE AND HE IS NOT
MAKING A DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE
PEOPLE CHARGED WITH SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY AND THOSE THAT
WATCHED THE RALLY AND WENT HOME.
I THINK THE CRITICISM FROM THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE IS
THAT SOMEHOW THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE EXCEEDED THEIR MANDATE
AND HAVE GONE BEYOND WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY.
BUT IT HASN'T, REALLY.
YOU CAN'T JUST LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED WITHIN A TWO-BLOCK
RADIUS OF CAPITOL HILL FOR TWO
HOURS ON JANUARY 6.
IT DID NOT JUST HAPPEN
ACCIDENTALLY.
IT DID NOT JUST HAPPEN RANDOMLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT LEGITIMATE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
THE PEOPLE BREAKING GLASS.
ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT PUT UP THE GALLOWS
TO SAY HANG MIKE PENCE.
THE PEOPLE THAT SIGNED FAKE
ELECTORAL VOTESA AT THE BEHEST
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IS IT LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE FOR JOHN EASTMAN AND
JEFFREY CLARK TO BASICALLY MAKE
FAKE THEORIES OVERRULING THE
CONSTITUTION AND 12th AMENDMENT
AND ELECTORAL COUNT ACT OF 1887.
THOSE TWO GUYS.
IS IT LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE, THOSE TWO THAT PLED
THE FIFTH AMENDMENT BEFORE THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE?
I DON'T THINK SO.
IF SOMEBODY WAS ENGAGED IN THAT
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO FEAR FROM
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> THAT MITT ROMNEY IS NOW SUCH
AN OUTLIER IN THE PARTY, A MAN
THAT WAS THE NOMINEE FOR THE
PARTY IS EXTRAORDINARY.
BILL CASSIDY SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST THE CENSURE OF CHENEY
AND KINZINGER.
IT IS STUNNING.
>> STUNNING AND SAD.
WE HAVE GONE FROM, YOU KNOW,